[موسيقى]
بحلم بس بعدين
لقيت
الدار كلها
اختي جنبيه كانت ناديت عليها وسمعت صوتها
فحاولت اني اشيل الركام عنها واشيل
الاشياء عليها
[موسيقى]
وجواله للاسف راح مع القصف
يوسف لما شفته ما كانش بتحرك ولا كان في
اي تعبير عليه فانا توقعت انه مستشهد ماما
بابا لما طلعوا ما كان في نبض
ماما كان في نبض بس ما كان في نفس فانا من
اول ما شفت من الثلاثه اتاكد
انه ممكن يصير هيك ممكن نفقد دارنا اوكي
اذا اخترت ببالي كتير بس انه ممكن احنا
نفقد حالنا في الدار مع توقعتها
[موسيقى]
انا اكثر كنت اخاف اموت ونصير اختي صغيره
لحالها او مثلا احنا نموت
عشان في حل مستشهد نستشهد المره هيكونوا
مع بعض
في غزه عم نفقد دور عم نفقد اهل عم نفقد
احبه عم يفقد طفولتنا احنا بنعيشها احنا
زي اي حدا تاني احيانا
بالحروب وحنموت على الحروب
[موسيقى]
الفخر انه انا كنت بنت لهذا الشخص والحمد
لله ان ربنا اصطفاه واخذوا الشهيد عند
رزقوا الشهاده وانا هيك ضمانه مجانيه اللي
جننت بسبب الثلاثه فالحمد لله يعني